[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días en france 24 este es
un magazine informativo 100% dedicado al
continente africano mi nombre eliana
valencia aquí damos una mirada en
profundidad a los hechos de actualidad
de la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
malikí del nuevo presidente interino
tras el golpe de estado del pasado 18 de
agosto
se trata de bando a quien estar en el
poder durante los próximos 18 meses al
tiempo el país el euro los 60 años de su
independencia
[Música]
se cumplen 50 años de la muerte de gamal
abdel nasser el legendario presidente de
egipto recordado como una de las
principales figuras del panarabismo y
también del panafricanismo y se realizó
en colombia la versión número 24 del
festival de música del pacífico petronio
álvarez esta vez de manera virtual
debido a la pandemia de kobe 19 el
evento logró acuerdos con otros
importantes festivales en sudáfrica
tanzania kenia y ghana
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días y empezamos en
mali porque la nación tiene un nuevo
presidente interino se trata del coronel
retirado bando a quien juró con la tarea
de liderar la transición de 18 meses de
regreso a un gobierno civil luego del
golpe de estado del pasado 18 de agosto
ahora la junta militar y los partidos
políticos esperan que su posesión
conduzca al levantamiento de las
sanciones impuestas por la comunidad
económica de estados de áfrica
occidental cedeao no aseguró que tomara
medidas enérgicas contra la corrupción
una de las principales quejas contra el
gobierno
de ibrahim abu bakr keita que denunció
tras ser detenido por militares
el aliento juro ante dios y el pueblo de
mal y defender el régimen republicano
pero sin república
de perseguir y hacer cumplir la
constitución el acuerdo de transición y
la ley de la luz
y cumplir con mis deberes para con el
pueblo defender los logros democráticos
garantizado asegurar la unidad la
independencia del país y la integridad
del territorio nacional
sin mangas
les juro solemnemente hacer todo lo
posible para trabajar por la unidad
africana
y seguimos el malí porque el país
celebró los 60 años de su independencia
este 22 de septiembre en medio de esta
difícil situación política esta es una
de las 17 naciones africanas que logró
su independencia en 1960 antes de la
república de malí existía la federación
de malí conformada por sudan francés y
por senegal
del 20 de junio de 1960 en dakar los
colores franceses dan paso a los de un
nuevo estado la federación de madrid
reúne dos antiguas colonias del áfrica
occidental francesa senegal y sudán
francés
[Música]
el ministro de estado luis aquino el
senegalés mamadou día y el sudanés
modibo keita realizan la transferencia
de competencias firmada el 4 de abril en
parís bajo la mirada del líder senegalés
léopold sédar senghor quien negoció
previamente con charles de gaulle
esa misma noche la asamblea federal de
malí votó de manera unánime por la
independencia
pero las celebraciones no duraron mucho
muy rápidamente se pusieron dos visiones
encarnadas por dos personalidades no
puedes en word aboga por la consulta con
francia cuando modibo keita adquiere un
estado fuerte y pan africano
young
[Música]
y el activismo por sí solo es un
estímulo para poblaciones que durante
mucho tiempo tuvieron una vida puramente
rural
rural y por lo tanto concientizamos a
nuestros jóvenes para capacitar a las
poblaciones en la perspectiva de su
movilización para el fortalecimiento
humanismo
el 18 de agosto modibo keita nombra
unilateralmente jefe de estado mayor del
ejército al coronel abdullah ya su madre
[Música]
en respuesta leopold senghor decretó el
estado de emergencia arrestó a su madre
y escoltó a modibo keita hasta en la
frontera el día 20 la asamblea de dakar
votó por la independencia de senegal
como entidad única
los sudaneses soñaban con un estado
unitario en el que no se hubieran
dominado gracias a su número y
disciplina diríamos un estado federal
muy flexible soñaban con concentra la
mayor parte del poder federal en manos
de un solo hombre queríamos un sistema
democrático de los poderes para
colaborar fueran compartidos
equilibrados
un mes después el sudan francés a su vez
proclama su independencia manteniendo la
referencia al glorioso imperio de maddie
uno de los más antiguos del continente
bajo el liderazgo de modibo keita en la
república de malí nació el 22 de
septiembre de 1960
y otra de estas 17 naciones es nigeria
que celebra su independencia del reino
unido- el primero de octubre de 1960
digería se independizó en esa fecha y
hoy junto a sudáfrica es el gigante
económico del continente africano y el
país más poblado con alrededor de 200
millones de habitantes
el país más poblado de áfrica se
independizó del reino unido- el primero
de octubre de 1960 los colonos
británicos llegaron a nigeria en la
década de 1850 la educación colonialista
impartida por misioneros cristianos
encontró una fuerte resistencia
especialmente de los líderes musulmanes
en el norte del país durante la
colonización el sur se desarrollo más
rápidamente que el norte esta división
tuvo consecuencias después de la
independencia los primeros movimientos
nacionalistas aparecen en la década de
1920 durante las siguientes cuatro
décadas la lucha contra la dominación
colonial continuó creciendo hasta lograr
la libertad total de la explotación
británica del territorio y el capital
humano después de la independencia
estallaron conflictos interétnicos entre
los causa en el norte y los tipos en el
este el jefe de este pueblo se llamaba
mk ocupo
este nuevo caos
si estalla una guerra civil y creo que
es inminente
geopark
ese será el precio a pagar por nuestra
libertad
en mayo en 1967 declaró la independencia
de la república de biafra en el este la
guerra civil comienza en julio
y sus tropas se enfrentan al ejército y
al líder nigeriano yakubu gowon vuelve
tarde los sacrificios serán altos pero
la causa es justa y loable viva la
federación de nigeria la guerra de
biafra duró hasta 1970 dejando miles de
víctimas como consecuencia de los
injustos repartos europeos de los
territorios africanos que dejaron grupos
étnicos enemigos dentro de las mismas
fronteras fue después de haber vivido
estos hechos que un grupo de
trabajadores humanitarios decidió fundar
la famosa ong médicos sin fronteras
y seguimos hablando de historia porque
se cumplen 50 años de la muerte de gamal
abdel nasser el 28 de septiembre de 1970
es recordado por enfrentarse a reino
unido al país colonialista que desde
1882 hasta 1956 se benefició de las
plantaciones de algodón a lo largo del
río nilo
el hardware gamal abdel nasser fue un
consagrado revolucionario desde joven en
1936 con el tratado a ángulo egipcio por
el cual egipto lograba la independencia
de los británicos
nasser se sintió profundamente
decepcionado al considerar que el
tratado de 1936 fue una traición en
aquellos días lidere manifestaciones en
el colegio de al nada gritando a todo
pulmón por una independencia total con
muchas personas siguiéndome pero
nuestros gritos murieron en ecos
desvanecidos arrastrados por los vientos
nasser asumió la presidencia del país en
1954 enfrentándose a grandes retos uno
de ellos recuperar el canal del suez y
lo logró aquella victoria valió la
expulsión de los ingleses de la zona y
lo puso en la esfera del liderazgo de
los movimientos el panarabismo y el
panafricanismo en su libro la filosofía
de la revolución
nasser expresó la necesidad de que
áfrica luchará conjuntamente para abolir
el colonialismo europeo
si dirigimos nuestra atención a un
segundo círculo el círculo del
continente de áfrica puedo decir sin
exagerar que no podemos así lo queramos
hacernos a un lado de la sanguinaria y
mortífera lucha que devora el corazón de
áfrica entre 5 millones de blancos y 200
millones de africanos tres años después
de haber perdido en la guerra de los
seis días contra israél un ataque
cardíaco le quitó la vida en 1970 con 52
años hoy 50 años más tarde es recordado
como uno de los principales líderes del
continente africano
vamos ahora a costa martín porque esta
nación de áfrica occidental está a un
mes de la celebración de las elecciones
presidenciales la población teme un
nuevo estallido de violencia como el que
se vivió después de las elecciones de
noviembre de 2010 desde abiyán nuestra
corresponsal marian cone nos envió
previamente el siguiente informe
el corazón de estas elecciones
presidenciales es la controvertida
candidatura de sandra mandaba el acto
del presidente que se presenta a un
tercer mandato los que se oponen a su
candidatura señalando que la
constitución del país limita el número
de mandato a 2 argumento rechazado por
el consejo constitucional del país que
aceptó la candidatura de aguantaba y
rechazó la de estos opositores
históricos logan huevo y guión show por
otra parte la cuarta africana pedir la
reinserción de estos dos candidatos en
la lista electoral y finalizamos con
cultura porque se realizó en colombia la
versión número 24 el festival de música
del pacífico petronio álvarez el
encuentro de la cultura negra más
importante de habla hispana esta vez el
evento se desarrolló de manera virtual y
se conectó también con eventos similares
en ghana sudáfrica kenia y tanzania en
una estrategia denominada los diálogos
panafricanos
el festival de música del pacífico
petronio álvarez reúne cada año
alrededor de 600.000 personas en torno a
la música la gastronomía la estética y
la producción académica afro colombiana
este año debido a la pandemia de kobe
los 19 elementos se desarrolló de manera
virtual y logró alianzas con otros
festivales de áfrica y las escuelas
hemos estado conversando con sudáfrica y
kenia tanzania ghana reunido y brasil en
estos festivales grandes donde tiene el
propósito de promocionar y visibilizar
la tradición del áfrica pero también la
tradición de la diáspora durante tres
días los principales exponentes de la
música del pacífico colombiano llegaron
a miles de hogares a través de las
plataformas digitales del festival y
junto a ellos las bebidas tradicionales
la gastronomía y la herencia africana
que en colombia está más viva que nunca
una vez más el petróleo demuestra su
resistencia su resiliencia a pesar de
cualquier cosa que suceda en su entorno
cada año el petronio álvarez se adapta a
las circunstancias y más allá de eso
sale
adelante con la energía del amor que
todas las personas que hacen parte de
este festival
agrupaciones emblemáticas de la región
como herencia de timbiquí la maestra
azul y morillo y el grupo bahía o la
pacífica mpower vivieron una experiencia
sin precedentes en un escenario
especialmente diseñado para mantener las
medidas de distancia social pero llegar
mucho más de cerca a los corazones que
este año entraña en asistir a elementos
olvidarnos de de esa numeración que
siempre acostumbra a ser del calor de la
gente y tratar desde hacerlo más desde
las emociones musicales
y que las sensaciones que produce estar
juntos creo que es una la zona más
interesante pero el petróleo no es sólo
un evento es un proyecto de desarrollo
cultural que continúa a lo largo de todo
el año promoviendo el fortalecimiento de
la tradición afro colombiana en el país
donde vive la diáspora hispanoparlante
más grande del planeta
y así a ritmo de marimba de chonta
finalizamos este capítulo de áfrica a 7
días ustedes pueden continuar con más
nuestra página web www punto frente 4
punto com nos vemos más adelante con más
información
[Música]